mais c'est un petit peu les cédric à
tous les soirs mais cédric 6 r et o
cédric et depuis hier j'ai vu que cédric
villani away l'ebre mathématicien
députés en marche et candidat à la
mairie de paris fait le buzz sur les
réseaux dans une vidéo on le voit dans
ces zones basses extrêmes super ambiance
et extraordinaire regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les basiques franchement on se dit voilà
s'asseoir et un casting joue pour danse
avec les stars
ça aurait été énorme samu l'imagerie ou
pas et merci pour danse avec les stars
mais pour la mairie de paris
ils vont envoyer un truc je sais pas
quoi je crois pas en tout cas serrée qui
dansent pas mal mais à côté ça danse on
dirait qu'à une ambiance de ouf on fait
aller y regarder on le voit bien dans
danse avec les stars sur coupé décalé
cédric villani sans aucun partenaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs on a une idée on s'est dit
est ce qu'on enverrait pas sacha à la
recherche de ses origines à 10h à notre
envoyé spécial et je crois qu'ils
valaient à l'assemblée nationale ou
alors on retrouvera dans un instant vous
me dites d'équilibré un sacha sacha
elbaz il s'appelle hael base
la wii est la base et d'ailleurs elle
s'en va très bien ça va très bien alors
ça vous plaît ça ou pas non non pas du
tout merci on voit par exemple ou que
justement dans quelques instants tout de
suite qu'en fin de chronique vous en
aller retour des zooms baba
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
zumba trois ans exceptionnels à propos
d'une chouette vous allez voir alors
attendant cyril hanouna vous récoltez
tout de suite mais revient sur la
chouette c'est obligé c'est à dire ça
c'est exceptionnel c'est magnifique j'ai
un des rares tissement pourquoi un
amortissement pourquoi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont changé dans
touche pas à mon poste depuis 2010 mais
ce qu elle pu changer c'est votre look
vous moquez de moi mais bon ne riez pas
alors vous changer de couleur de cheveux
aussi souvent que deux chroniqueurs on
va voir contre la première est
aujourd'hui autant de différence entre
vous que mokhtar et passe partout en
fait c'est la même chose
et pour faire plaisir j'ai remis quand
même le petit coup comme ça quand vous
ambiancer tout le monde regardez
la mare des émissions médias sérieuse
n'est ce pas le public dans le métro ou
de cnn en 2010 c'était sobriété en 2019
c'est plutôt on ne peut pas vous raté à
gauche au vendeur en porte-à-porte de
vérandas à droite le sosie officiel de
dj snake
franchement il ya tellement de
différences entre ces deux personnes que
vous pourriez faire patron incognito et
sur le plateau 2010 avec peu d'écho fut
en ligue des champions
denis brogniart avec la coupe bouclettes
effet cheveux mouillés
christophe carrière et a opté pour les
faits cheveux dégueulasse jean-michel
minc a choisi les faits je suis le seul
à croire que j'ai encore des cheveux et
puis surtout ces trois personnes m'ont
fait penser à des stars de 30 millions
d'amis
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
j'adorerais c'est exceptionnel
franchement c'est gentil nationale et où
il ya beaucoup de travail dont nous
sommes le 10 septembre 2019 pas d'un
foule mais le 10 septembre 2015 vous
receviez loana l'onac et a fait
fantasmer tous les français bien sûr et
qui avait avoué sur le plateau que
julien courbet était son fantasme alors
série avec votre taxe et surtout votre
discrétion s'embrasser vous parlez de
moi loi n'allait pas contre mais julien
bof ils essaient de se faire très
discret regarder sa tête c'est
magnifique et mériter les félicitations
bien sûr je viens combes et vous avez
vous le trouviez un peu sexy oui je
trouve que ça l'animateur le plus sexy
chevaux
[Applaudissements]
et
alors regardez de couler vous avez
l'espace d'art cas avec un enfant qui
kiffent sa rage parce que deux personnes
vont s'embrasser fait de l'autre
l'espace sera sera privé courbet qui
n'arrivent pas à masquer son malaise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces nouvelles
[Applaudissements]
lula à la mer arrêté voilà l'arbre à ce
jugement
alors c'est pour 2016 dans tpm peut on a
vécu un moment inoubliable avec une
personnalité vous avez cassé la boîte
merci donc aux états unis qui est cette
personne évidemment en pyramide donc ils
vont en trois phases i à iii animal
animal ce cochon sont cool raoul hiboux
chouettes bravo et un braquage est temps
de passer à nant au choix de gates alors
je vais pas le faire comme ça
chouette gates est un des moments je
pense les plus importants et les plus
drôles de l'histoire y avait de tvnp
vous allez revenir sur le choix de game
explosif je crois que c'est un des plus
gros fous rires donc toute ma vie
entière ne peut pas le jeter comme ça
bien sûr que non on va se trouver dans
un instant franchement c'est pas
pourquoi en 2016 via décidé d'engager
l'âme en tant que chroniqueuse bon
j'adore a été très sympa et
malheureusement c'est que l'espérance de
vie d'un chroniqueur des pmp environs de
six émissions que vous réalisiez un gros
coup de quoi s attendait il y en a qui
sont là depuis longtemps mais bon à la
moyenne grâce à sa 6e voilà c'est ça
comme ont réalisé un gros coup avec
l'âme dans l'équipe vous avez voulu
faire un jeu pour deviner qui était dans
la chouette sauf qu'on est tombé sur la
seule chouette qui avait le vertige
alors en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
l'on la mise en show est oui c'est pas
pourquoi allez c'est bon c'est parti
laissez vous le connaissez le principe
de la chouette mais je vous le redire la
chouette c'est un nouveau chroniqueur ou
une nouvelle chroniqueuse qu'il va nous
rejoindre
un mot c'est qu on s'est posé la
question voilà alors la chouette est dit
non
là vous comprenez de la jouette ne va
pas bien du tout et vous tombez que le
risque que sa vie évidemment qu'est ce
que vous faites vous rigolez pas mais
alors là souhaite veut descendre
apparemment la chouette n'est pas bien
la chouette enfin saine et sauve les
chroniqueurs peuvent essayer de deviner
qui sera leur prochaine collecte de soi
la chouette at-elle la chance comme vous
et moi d'être d'obédience maghrébine ou
pour ça qui est l'âme du site en
revêtant votre costume de pippo man que
vous dites à une meuf avec une perruque
rose déguisés ont chouette cette phrase
mythique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je demande la spa qu'est ce qu'elle est
belle on a beaucoup lu ces images moi je
m'intéresse à ce qui se passe dans
l'émission parce que maintenant que la
chouette est descendu du plafond vous
dit ça y est oui on va pouvoir voir une
émission n'aura bien sûr et bien pas du
tout pas du tout c'est là que le
meilleur commence une fois qu'elle est
assise à la table pire arrive
regardez votre relation avec lahm va
aller crescendo je pense qu'on va
rigoler alors déboursé rigole avec elle
mais tout de suite vous allez avoir un
petit doute
[Rires]
[Musique]
comment voyez qu'elle a un peu le
boulard nous fait une vaine pour
désamorcer le truc le net il m'a dit
qu'il rentre pas non mais je repars tout
à fait d'accord bien comme mathieu non
et quand elle se croit un peu trop chez
elle vous avez du mal à cacher que vous
êtes un peu agacé la niçoise par là et
tout le monde ici a compris qu'on ne
reverrait jamais dans tpm c'est tout le
monde sauf l'âme bien convaincant
les personnes
ils sont
et franchement je suis attirée futur
c'est vrai que mine de rien je la kiffe
vraiment toujours en plus vraiment des
gains de plus en plus à cause de ça
c'est donc je sais pour un bibelot chez
soi ces jours ci et donc on va terminer
parce qu'en voyant cette émission avec
l'âme j'aurais pu faire au moins 10 ou
baba mais j'ai choisi les meilleurs
moments où vraiment vous êtes halluciné
par son comportement ou parce qu'elle
dit voici en conclusion pour la première
fois un triple zumba a compris
c'est quoi comme enterrement de vie de
jeune fille tient vous suffit maintenant
qu'elle un terme à coiffer les créations
voilà c'est une création
je ne voulais pas aller chanter pour
cette saison
[Applaudissements]